Scientists may have developed gene therapy
that effectively prevents AIDS.
But HIV may have mutated to bypass the new
defenses.
Gah, HIV, you are such a piece of sh-
Hello viewers, I hope you’re healthy and
well out there, Julian here for DNews.
Researchers at the Scripps Research Institute
believe they are on track to a gene therapy
that will effectively render most strains
of HIV impotent.
The Human Immunodeficiency Virus works by
targeting CD4+ T Cells, which are white blood
cells that play a key role in your adaptive
immune system - that’s the part that helps
you fight infections.
HIV latches onto them by grabbing onto the
CD4 protein on the T cell’s surface, and
then clamping down on another receptor called
CCR5.
Once it’s in position, it inserts its own
RNA into the cell, tricking it into making
more viruses.
It basically turns the good guy cells into
zombies.
Once enough T Cells are turned, the infected
person’s immune system is compromised and
vulnerable and they have Acquired Immune Deficiency
Syndrome, or AIDS.
Unfortunately no effective vaccine has been
developed yet.
The problem with retroviruses like HIV is
they change and adapt quickly.
It’s like whack-a-mole with the deadliest
mole ever.
And of course there are many strands, so a
vaccine against one strand probably won’t
be effective against others.
Now though scientists think they’re on to
something.
Dr. Michael Farzan and other researchers say
they’ve created a tiny strand of DNA which,
when injected into muscle tissue, stimulates
the cells to synthesize a claw-shaped protein.
For proteins, shapes are everything, and this
claw is HIV’s worst nightmare.
It’s simple enough that even if the virus
changes, it likely won’t be able to shake
the claw.
The protein works by latching on to the CD4
and CCR5 binding sites on the virus, leaving
it adrift and unable to latch on to T Cells.
If it can’t latch on, it can’t replicate.
Eventually it’s broken down and disposed
of harmlessly.
This isn’t just some flash in the test tube
either.
They’ve already been testing this on 4 monkeys
by giving them the gene therapy and then injecting
them with a strain of HIV for lab monkeys,
called the Simian/Human Immunodeficiency Virus.
After nearly a year, the Macaques are A-OK.
Now they’re looking to treat infected monkeys
to see if it can stop the virus from replicating
further.
If that’s a success, they’re looking to
begin human trials.
Don’t worry, they won’t be injecting humans
with HIV to test it, they’ll be giving the
protein and gene to those either with HIV
or those at high risk.
As always, nothing is guaranteed until it
happens, but it looks promising.
Of course, the world being what it is, researchers
in Cuba believe they have found a new strain
of HIV that skips the CCR5 bonding site and
goes straight for the one known as CXCR4.
Normally HIV transitions to the CXCR4 protein
after years, during which time the host is
relatively healthy.
Once it switches though the descent to AIDS
begins.
This new strand, which researchers believe
is the combination of several other HIV subtypes,
fast tracks AIDS leading to earlier death.
It’s no more infectious than its predecessors,
but it might render this new treatment ineffective.
So, one step forward and one step back?
But keeping things on the positive tip - if
scientists can keep that new strain from spreading,
then we may have an effective treatment for
all the other variants of HIV in the pipeline.
One day HIV may be some terrifying disease
that only exists in history books and memories,
like polio is to our grandparents.
I hope I’m around to see that day.
While this isn’t technically a vaccine,
I’m sure the public will think of it as
such and of course, there will be skeptics.
Here to say once again that vaccines do not
cause autism is Trace, because apparently
that still needs to be said.
check it out over here.
What’s your reaction to the news?
Hopeful?
Skeptical?
What are your reasons?
Let us know in the comments and I’ll see
you next time on DNews.